coldplay won a grammy with their first
album parachutes i would say yellow was
the biggest song off of that
this one
look at the stars
the car they shine for
you
beautiful beautiful song everything but
uh chris frustrates me i'm glad the
whole band is here i've asked him what
this song is about because i have no
idea what that song is about and
i'm i don't think he said as
well i'm adding a few words i mean
seriously you have no idea what that
song is about though
really it's a gorgeous song it is it's a
wonderful song um well that's what i if
i may remind you
that when that song arrived
yeah you and johnny were playing
fifa or whatever that football game was
okay
in the lounge yeah the studio and i came
through and i said hey listen to this
and this is what you guys did
that's good yeah
[Laughter]
and then i remember then i went to the
bathroom and the chorus came through and
i was playing the chorus in the bathroom
and i came back and i said hey listen to
this
and these two were like that's good yeah
they had no ability to recognize that
you had just written a hit song is that
correct
well we didn't know what that song was
but none at all no they were just
interested in but also to be fair was
quite different to how it ended up i
believe it was to be fair heavy metal
it was like it was the sort of vaguely
kneel youngish
uh slightly less
well it's a bit it had a different
slower tempo it was no it wasn't the
smash that no but it came to be
will are you too hard on chris when he
writes a new song i i do genuinely feel
terrible a lot of the time about
um
about having to
say
my voice my opinion on things and it's
difficult and and i also have to have
learned to to just keep quiet a lot of
the time because as
i know that i've been i've made some
terrible mistakes in the past
judging a song too too early i said that
song clocks that's rubbish that's not
even a song i think is what i said
chris brought you the song clocks he
brought it to the band
and will you go that's really bad
by the way it felt like yeah it didn't
have a chorus it still doesn't really
it's a wonderful piece of music and
i think that i was stuck in a kind of
mold of thinking that everything needed
to have a
i was very narrow-minded i would say in
terms of what chorus or what a song
could be and
uh i fully i i ate my hat on that one
many years ago but i'll if it still
needs eating i'll keep i'll keep
munching away but
we're being howard the truth is that um
is it in lord of the rings where there's
saruman and then there's sauron who's
the really bad guy right so
no so you're as well you're like the
wizard that's pretty bad okay but guys
like the wizard you don't want to
with at all oh really if guy says he
doesn't like a song there's no point
ever playing it again
guy did you hate that song when chris
brought you clocks you liked it
yeah i got it immediately
right
johnny what about you
what was your reaction honestly i think
everything's going to be brilliant i'm
annoyingly positive about about
everything i have no filter whatsoever
so
i just get i just get excited when
there's new music and want to play on it
let's say you write a song and will says
to you because he's so evil he goes this
is a horrible song um chris do you then
lay awake and i say why did i listen to
well maybe that is a hit song i mean you
got to be careful right the truth is
he's never guided us wrong
the balance of the four of us and phil
our fifth
and whoever we're working with is like i
trust that um
shape of things and uh i know that if if
i really believe in something i just
gotta keep keep chiseling away and then
at some point if it's really good will
we'll say okay that's
that's good
for whatever reason ever it just works
the way it works it does it's difficult
sometimes but
um i wouldn't have it any other way